[Music]
he's a singer he's a dancer he's an icon
and he wrote The Single catchiest hook
in the history of music please welcome
Cisco
[Applause]
what's up
good
[Applause]
Cisco hey hey
he's here he's talking to me okay Cisco
you are an amazing singer a Flawless
dancer and a Caesar cut innovator
your music is infectious and I have
literally never taken a road trip
without screaming one of your many hits
out the window thank you so much for
being here thank you for all of those
beautiful accolades thank you so much
okay
those Mega hit the Thong Song are
memorable it's impossible to get them
wrong but the Amber Ruffin show asks
what if you did
what would that sound like well let's
find out right now in America's newest
game show the wrong song
[Music]
[Applause]
that wasn't what I had in mind
we're never gonna use this again I'm
gonna bring it right on out anytime take
this home absolutely absolutely here's
how it'll work Cisco and I will take
turns asking each other questions and
our answer will have to rhyme with the
famous line from The Thong Song Cisco
are you ready always
okay for round one all of our answers
will have to rhyme with the line dumps
like a truck truck truck here we go
and Cisco oh the little black thing in
hockey is called
uh a uh Puck Puck puck
yes I live in Minnesota now so you know
oh yeah oh okay that was easy assistant
would you like to ask me a question sure
all right uh a person of color curses at
their mom they better what they better
duck duck duck right
that's right
okay nailed it folks it's tied
do women do to their eyebrows
what do women do to their eyebrows when
what happens when they get unruly oh
okay uh
I don't know
we pluck pluck oh oh painful painful it
does it does hurt right right hey you
know Beauty pain sometimes eyebrows just
go well thank you thank you
hit me all right a Yiddish word that
means you're a jerk
you're you're you're you're you're
you're you're a schmuck schmuck schmuck
nailed it
all right now that is the end of round
one all right I have two scores I have
two points it's one score guys this is
how scores were I only have one score
the one score is two points okay and
Cisco has one point one Cisco the
competition is intense are you buckling
underneath all this pressure
yeah yeah
[Applause]
I had to sneak that in there
bring it don't you call that [ __ ] A
Sneak I wanna hear it all the time round
two for this round all of our answers
will have to rhyme with the line fast
like what what what do you got it yeah I
got it okay let's go
sisky can I call you Siskey only you
only you Amber
Cisco this Star Wars character loves
pizza Pizza Hut huh I'll take it I'll
take it
maybe his friends call him Pizza like I
call Cisco sister
all right
um if RuPaul says
uh Shantae you stay
what should you do you bet you reviewed
you better stretch stretch stretch yeah
that's it that's what you do
yeah Cisco I have a question for you
it's quite important okay if your throat
closes after you eat a PB and J you
might be allergic to a
[Laughter]
nuts nuts nuts
[Applause]
now when older black people eat ice
cream
it gives them a bloated
gives them a bloated butt butt
we were looking for gut but of course we
prefer butt right guys
[Applause]
what I wouldn't give or uploaded but
okay that is the end of round two now
the score is Amber Mildred Ruffin with
three points
and Cisco Siskey Cisco with three points
inside all right okay
that's that's my government name by the
way
just just the most unoriginal mom of all
yep that was it three of the same names
she was just describing the pain
okay Cisco everything could change in
our last and most challenging round in
round three every answer must rhyme with
the memorable they catch me the iconic
line
are you ready all right yeah let's do it
okay Cisco buddy is 4 20. I want to see
your
oh
laughs
that is correct
all right uh they should have left this
big dude in the jungle he he climbed it
there we go
yeah they really should have they
bothered that monkey he was having a
nice time yeah all right with another an
unfortunate name for a delicious snack
cake
[ __ ]
yeah now table tennis is just a fancy
name for
oh ping pong pong pong pong
[Applause]
okay Cisco our last and final question
is this what is the world's most
uncomfortable type of underwear
say with me that
hey
ladies and gentlemen the final score is
ever recorded with five points and Cisco
siski Cisco with six boys
it wins plus Cisco gets an extra 100
points for putting up with this nonsense
which means this guy
[Applause]
so bad for joining us today and thank
you for watching the wrong song yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]